Tom Brady, the quarterback of the New England Patriots...
...is not only one of the NFL's best players,...
...he's one of the NFL's great stories.
At the tender age of 30,...
...he has already won 3 Super Bowls,...
...an accomplishment that ranks him with some of the best quarterbacks...
...ever to play the game.
And he is having one of the greatest seasons in pro football history.
When we first reported on him back in 2005,...
...he seemed underrated and almost overlooked.
He doesn't have the arm of Peyton Manning and he doesn't have tattoos.
And he doesn't take steroids,...
...and he's never held out for more money.
All he knows how to do is win.
Former football greats say he exemplifies what the American athlete should be.
Yet, he barely made it to the NFL at all.
For much of his high school and college careers,...
...he was a second stringer, battling for the starting job.
He wasn't picked until the sixth round of the NFL draft.
The 199th player chosen.